hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast predictive gene signatures
molecular markers distinguishing colon
adenomatous polyp and carcinoma we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by av psyx i am judy o'rourke
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the q a box
which can be found by clicking on the
green q a button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem to the
green q a button lower left i would now
like to introduce today's speaker janice
drew phd dr drew is a senior research
fellow msc human nutrition course
coordinator for molecular nutrition in
heroic institute of nutrition and health
within the college of life sciences and
medicine at the university of aberdeen i
will now turn it over to dr drew for her
presentation
okay um
so today i'd like to
present some of the work from my lab on
the
development approaches that we've used
to
produce predictive gene signatures using
multiplexed gene expression profiling
the advent of microarray
technologies has led to a
massive increase in and eliminated a new
molecular complexity
in carcinogenesis
identifying aberrant gene signatures
associated with initiation and
progression
and the focus in my lab has been on
distilling the discovery of these broad
molecular signatures
into smaller gene sets of
appropriate density to allow us to
develop clinical
asses that have potential to identify
and measure predictive gene signatures
and this would
specifically
allow us to develop diagnostic tools to
use
predictive gene signatures
in disease detection and staging
and also progression
and also allow us to have an insight
into
selecting appropriate therapeutic
or identifying therapeutic responses and
also selecting treatments that have
efficacy and compliance
and this prompted us to
explore multiplex gene expression
profiling
and we looked at the genome lab system
this um
was specifically because this allowed us
the options to multiplex gene expression
acids
using around 20 to 30 gene targets
and we could also custom design these
in-house
and
very importantly when using clinical
samples we were able to use very small
amounts of starting material
so hopefully during this webinar
i'll be able to
highlight the potential of multiplexed
gene expression
developing in-house
multiplex gene expression
assays
and to demonstrate the potential for
cancer screening and detection
and
also looking at how these may be used in
developing drugs and also the selection
of effective interventions for
individual patients and of course this
is becoming increasingly important as we
seek to stratify approaches to
patients
so the aspects that i will specifically
look at are
issues around the design of the
multiplexes
issues surrounding tissue optimization
of
i'll take a look at
some of the issues that multiplexing has
provoked around total rna quality
and i'll also take a look at some of the
analytical and clinical validation
work that we've done with the
genome lab system gene expression
technology platform
i'd then like to finish off by
focusing on an application of our
in-house custom designed
gexp asses
to
assess
tissue status and pathology
so our first multiplex
came about following a macro array study
in which we um
had tried to identify inflammatory gene
targets that were associated with the
early events in colon carcinogenesis
and this was conducted using a targeted
microarray
of around 100 genes
and this identified 14 gene targets that
showed differential in
expression
in adenoma and cardinals carcinoma
samples when compared to normal tissue
we then set about validating these 14
targets using a single plexed real-time
pcr approach
and this validated the gene expression
results from the microwave study
our next step
was of course to then take these gene
targets forward into a further clinical
validation in which we would attempt to
verify that these were these gene
targets were
differentially regulated in larger
patient sets
but of course the microarray and the
real-time study was obviously a fairly
time consuming
exercise and we were looking for
something that would speed up our
processing of tissue samples
and this prompted a further look at the
genome lab system
and the options within that for
multiplexed rna quantitation
and this led to the development of a
multiplex assay which incorporated all
14 of these gene targets in a single
assay so that we could measure
the 14 gene targets simultaneously in a
single reaction
and
this also allowed us an opportunity to
validate the
genome system
technology platform against both of the
other gene expression technology
platforms that we'd used for this study
so what i'd like to do now is
just take you through some of the
processes that are now routinely
employed in my lab
in custom designing of gene expression
assays and i'd like to use the h inflam
plex as an example of how we developed
this approach
the first
step of course is to select the gene
targets that you wish to multiplex and
in this case we had already selected our
14 targets from the macroarray
and real-time pcr analysis
so we gather the session numbers for
these
and uh
this is all uh
recorded into a master file that we keep
we keep a spreadsheet of our multiplexes
and as is now routine we
we incorporate uh
perhaps two to three uh reference genes
in each of our multiplexes in this case
we had already used gap dh and b2m
for validation of the real-time targets
and also in the microarray so it made
sense to incorporate these
targets in the multiplex
the next step is that these
the
sequences which are
associated with the session numbers are
then
uploaded into the genome lab system
software system
and we use the express profiler
component of this to actually design
our gene-specific
primers for each of the targets
we then take each of those primers and
we will then run them through some sort
of search engines such as blast
just to
make sure that they don't have any off
targets or non-target homology it's
going to cause problems in the asses
and we also gather information on the
structural information of each of the
targets such as intron exon boundaries
for example and we try to ensure we're
possible that our primary assets will
amplify of course across the intro and
x1 boundaries
when we're happy with the primary
selections
we then begin
to conduct
the first step of optimizing the rca
now this requires of course
choosing your template rna
in our case we've been using
colon
mucosa
and this slide just simply shows a
typical colon mucosal sample this one
actually is
an ex-evil cultured colon explant but
from this you can clearly see from the
grade
gradated scale here
that these are very small tissue samples
and we typically use around 20 to 13
milligrams of tissue for rna extraction
following the extraction we then assess
quality using both agilent analysis and
also nanodrop spectrophotometry
now for those of you unfamiliar with the
genome system gexp asses um i will just
take uh
go through the next couple of slides
just the principles behind the assays
now of course when we design a new
multiplex the first step is to actually
then conduct a single plex of each of
our individual chain specific primary
assets to ensure that we amplify a
single tag a single fragment of the
expected size
so each of our
targets is amplified using a
gene-specific primer which is denoted by
the
purple bar here
and each of these
has a universal tag attached indicated
by the red bar
so reverse transcription is uh proceeds
with a gene-specific reversal
gene-specific reverse primer
and during the first one to three cycles
of pcr
this proceeds with the gene-specific
primers for forward and reverse and both
of these have a universal tag attached
in the subsequent rounds of pcr
amplification is then performed using
the universal primers alone and the
forward universal primer
has a
fluorescent tag attached
so the outcome of this is that we
generate fluorescently tagged
amplicons uh specific for our gene
target
and these are fluorescently labeled
once we're satisfied that each of our
primaries produces a single fragment of
the expected size we then begin
to optimize the multiplex so the reverse
primers are
mixed in a master mix
and each of these will
be used to conduct the multiplex
reaction
so during this reaction we then amplify
each of our
targets simultaneously in a single
reaction
and we end up with a mixture of reaction
products
which are all fluorescently labeled at
the 5 prime end
and each of these primers
each of these gene targets
amplified gin targets differs in size by
around five to seven bases
we then take these
amplified fragments
and subject them to capillary
electrophoresis and fragment analysis
using the genetic analysis system
so following capillary electrophoresis
we obtain
a readout that looks something like this
this is an electro ferrogram here
each of the panels
represents a reaction on
that's been conducted in triplicate
and this is a routine procedure that we
process the reactions in triplicate
from these electrophiles
products you can see from the blue peaks
here each of these represents one of our
amplified targets within the multiplex
and the red peaks
indicates
the position of a size standard that's
incorporated with the pcr reaction prior
to capillary electrophoresis
and this allows us to then or allows the
software to actually assign sizes to
each of these
amplified fragments and you can see that
in the electrophilogram here
and we obviously then check that each of
these is appropriate for the expected
sizes within our multiplex
now the size uh
sizes are are signed using a size filter
for each multiplex and from this we can
then get a readout of the gene
expression levels
which is associated with each
peak on the electropherogram
and at this stage we usually export that
data into spreadsheet and we can then
use one or
two or three of the
potential reference genes to
calculate normalization
now an important
aspect of this stage is to ensure that
all of our amplified fragments are
within the linear range for the rca
and in the initial stages
of optimizing the inform plex we
actually used a mixture of
template which consisted of a one to one
to one mix of rna extracted from normal
adenoma and carcinoma tissues
however when we came to apply this into
the individual tissue samples
we did have some further optimization to
do because of course when you move
through
the
stages of disease initiation and
progression
you tend to have quite large
changes in gene expression
indeed often in carcinoma we have a
gene expression which almost drops out
and new genes appear
so in order to capture this linear range
we conducted some further attenuation in
each individual tissue sample
status
and this is simply
performed by
titrating
reverse primary concentrations in the
multiplex mix
and what we're trying to do is ensure
that we can
identify our targets across the three
different tissue states and that these
are within linear range
for relative quantitation
so from this then we can output our
final multiplex and this is the
infamplex here and you can see here
on the right hand side
the right hand column
the final selected reverse primer
concentrations for this multiplex
so once we have the multiplex optimized
for the
template tissues that we are testing
we can then conduct a
multiplex gene expression assays
so the samples that were used in the
original microarray and real-time pcr
analysis
uh were now
subjected to gene expression profiling
using the hm complex which measured all
14 targets simultaneously in each tissue
sample
and from this we could compile a bar
chart here
which simply shows the mean expression
levels in each of the
normal adenoma and carcinoma samples
now when we compared the
gene expression data obtained using the
hm flamplex
against the gene expression data that we
had gathered from the macro rate and
real-time pcr analysis
we could clearly see that those gene
targets which showed uh down regulation
when assessing using macrae at real-time
pcr
also showed a down regulation
when measured using the hm complex
likewise those genes that showed an up
regulation indicated by the green
arrows here
we also obtained uh an upregulation
within form plex
so this was very encouraging
and
this prompted us to proceed with a
further clinical validation
using the inframplex to assess gene
expression in a new patient tissue set
and we obtain these tissues from the t
site tissue bank in dundee in scotland
so this table now shows um
a comparison of the gene expression of
our 14 targets measured using the each
inflam plex
and comparisons with the previous
samples which were collected from the
aberdeen tissue bank
so in the table here you can see
normal
versus adenoma and normal versus
carcinoma
gene expression the red colored boxes
indicate a down regulation compared to
these and the green represents an up
regulation and you can see there's a
fair degree of uh convergence across the
table and that
when we have genes that were down
regulated in the aberdeen tissue bank
set
they're usually
also downregulated in the scientific
bank set and likewise for those genes
that were upgraded
now um when we uh
this was particularly encouraging
because as we proceeded with the
clinical validation
and we were testing larger patient sets
we were less
choosy about selecting samples with the
best rna quality i should mention that
when we conducted the macroarray
and real-time pcr study on the aberdeen
tissue bank set
we actually selected those tissue
samples that gave us a good quality rna
however
the the
quality of clinical samples is
notoriously variable and you can see
here that when we have poor
tissue bank samples and per clinical
samples we tend to have a
correspondingly uh
poor quality of rna which is shown in
the agilent traces here on the right
and in the top
right you can see that
the ribosomal peaks indicate a fair
amount of degradation is the sample
um
so some of the anomalies between our
t-side tissue bank set and the aberdeen
tissue set may partly be due to
differences in rna quality but also they
reflect the heterogeneity of the
clinical samples and also the hydrogen
heterogeneity in carcinoma
i thought it might be useful to just
take a closer look at one of the
individual gene targets within the
multiplex
and examine this more closely
the charts here show gene expression
measured in individual patient samples
in normal and dark blue here normal
versus adenoma in blue and normal versus
carcinoma in pink
and you can see in the aberdeen tissue
bank patient set real-time pcr
gene expression and adenoma and
carcinoma compared to normal
you can see that the carcinoma typically
express a higher degree of variation in
gene expression
when we compare
the gene expression measured using the h
and pharmaplex um
assay on the aberdeen tissue patient
said you can see that these are broadly
similar in fact they're very similar
um and then when we come to the larger
patient set that was tested from the uh
t secretary bank again you can see
similar ranges of expression and
variation and again this higher level of
expression or variation in expression in
carcinoma samples but they're
broadly similar and this gave us some
confidence in proceeding with the
development of the multiplex asses
we were able to demonstrate that we
could obtain comparable gene expression
patterns using different gene expression
technology platforms and that the
multiplex
was
performed favorably in comparison with
these
we're also able to then apply
our multiplex to conduct
clinical validation of uh
identified individual targets
and compared these
against the initial analysis
and this also highlighted
that we were able to obtain gene
expression profiles using the multiplex
gene expression assay
even when the rna quality was less than
optimal
and during this procedure we also
learned a bit about
tissue optimization
our inequality and also
the sample heterogeneity issues
and i'll see a bit more about those
as i proceed
so this gave us confidence then to
look at the future potential of the gexp
technology platform
to allow us to investigate
the functioning regulation and
characterization of gene expression
profiles
and of multiple using multiple targets
in biopsy tissues
so i'd like to
during the remainder of this webinar
focus on the application of multiplex
gene expression profiling
and to identify gene's signatures in
human clinical samples
now as i mentioned earlier
carcinogenesis is
associated with aberrant molecular
signatures that are associated with
disease initiation and progression
and typically we only have small amounts
of these tissues for
assay
and
as i've already highlighted they exhibit
a broad heterogeneity and this is
contributed by
the genetic variation
across different individuals
it can be caused by
variation in the tissue location from
which the surgeon collects the samples
and then added to that we also have the
heterogeneity that is associated with
diseased tissue and in particular
carcinomas can actually have areas of
necrotic tissue and these often build
very poor quality rna
and we're also aware that clinical
samples are often not collected um
optimally for
preserving rna quality
so taking all these issues
into
mind
we were still confident that the gene
lab system would be able to allow us to
measure
gene expression
and
and
we're also aware of course that this
broad heterogeneity
excludes the use of single biomarkers
and multiplexing then becomes absolutely
crucial in identifying uh predictive
gene signatures
the other aspect of the multiplex arces
that
is very useful is that they're flexible
and that and by that i mean we can
actually custom design and we can
remove or
add in new targets as these become
as these are discovered or as they
become
a target of interest
so we can modify these assets as we as
we proceed
so this multiplex the hcl markerplex rca
attempts to capture that broad
heterogeneity and it incorporates 21
cell markers which
mark various cellular processes which
include epithelial
cell determination
we also have cell differentiation
cell survival and apoptotic markers
and various structural determinants
as is now routine we include
a couple of reference genes and here
we've used b2m and ubc h5b
and we also include the synthetic
transcripts can r
which is supplied with the genome lab
system acid kits
and this synthetic transcript simply
allows us to measure reaction
efficiency during the
reverse transcription and pcr
now as with our previous studies
we were aware that there was a range of
uh total rna quality in our clinical
samples and in this study we noted
values
from
as low as two up to a run value of 10
which
is at the high end the quality scale
so we attempted using linear
discriminant discriminant analysis to
identify a potential cutoff
whereby we would
obtain or maximize
correctly classified tissue samples
based on gene expression profiles
and you can see from this chart here
that we have this
step here at around
five so we set this as our cut off uh
for one co for our inequality
however you'll note from the y-axis here
that
even down to the lower rim values we
still have a high percentage of
correctly classified tissues based on
the
gene expression profiles obtained
okay so once we have
once we had applied the h-cell
markerplex acid to our normal
adenomatous pop and carcinoma tissue
samples
we exported the data and this was
normalized and then we conducted a
principal component analysis
and this simply allows us to look at
clustering patterns associated with the
gene expression profiles
and you can see here that there were a
couple of anomalies
we appeared to have
uh carcinoma samples that were
clustering
with the normal tissues in blue here
we then
took these uh took this up with the
pathologists
and
established that actually one of these
was a mislabeling and the tumor sample
the carcinoma sample was actually normal
in the second case we actually uh
attributed this to the fact that this
tissue sample was taken from a very
large carcinoma which uh
exhibited a very high
degree in variation in dysplasia and it
may be that the tissue sample
was taken exhibited a more normal
profile or was taken from a more normal
area of the carcinoma and this
highlights an important issue in
clinical sampling and
we would anticipate that of course it
might it might be necessary
to conduct multiple sampling of these
casting casting samples with the
multiplexes
so these two diesel sets were removed
and we
ended up with a final principal
component analysis uh biplot that looks
something like this
and this simply allows us as i said to
identify clustering patterns in the
tissue and we can see here that the
normal tissues tend to cluster and the
position of each of the genes on the
bioplot indicate potential classifier
genes which are contributing
to this clustering pattern so
when we now uh
compile the gene expression data
and construct a bar chart showing the
main expression levels we end up
with this
graph here which shows us the mean
expression levels in normal adenomatous
and carcinoma and then by conducting an
anova we can identify those genes that
are differentially expressed
in individual tissues
so the principle component analysis and
the
statistical analysis of the mean
expression data
allows to identify um
the fact that obviously the pathology
plays a
significant part
in the gene expression patterns observed
but it doesn't establish whether or not
we could assign
tissue status or tissue pathology based
on the
gene expression
patterns alone
and to do this we used an orthogonal
orthogonal partial least squares
discriminant analysis and that's shown
in the plot on the right here
and this multiple regression analysis
allows us to discriminate the gene sets
of the gene expression data
by maximizing covariance
to assign
tissue status based on the gene
expression pattern of the gene
expression signature from the multiplex
from this we can also
compile a variable importance plot
and from this it's possible to identify
that collagen 1a1 and slc-982
are particularly important in
discriminating
and
adenomatic carcinoma and if we go back
to the plot here you can see that that
collagen
is situated up here and
slc 92 is at the
opposite end
and
it's important of course to point out
here that you can see that the
opls discriminate analysis
uh in component one here we go we have a
complete separation of the normal
tissues indicated by the open triangles
here
and in component two we separate the
adenoma the great filled triangles from
the
carcinoma the black triangles in the
upper right quadrant
from the rank importance plot uh again
we also can see that those genes that
are
situated towards the left hand of the
plot are also some of the important
genes that
are
contributing to
the discrimination of each of the tissue
types
from this we can also then produce a
matrix which simply established that we
were able to
correctly identify one hundred percent
of the normal tissue samples
and uh correctly identify uh
88.24 and 94.12
of the adenoma and carcinoma samples
respected
so if we go back to the principle
principle component analysis by port
this indicates potential classifier
genes and highlights those genes that we
might want to take forward for further
investigation and validation
and there are
just a few that i'd like to point out
for example
ms-4812 here
is actually a colon specific epithelial
marker
we took this forward
for further validation and you can see
in this in situ hybridization
that this particular transcript has a
very specific
localization on the surface the luminal
surface epithelium of the colon here and
you can see that by this the white
staining on the
brake field image here
the institute also confirmed of course
our multiplexed gene expression
profiling in that we have a
loss of expression of this
transcript in the adenoma and we see a
variable pattern in the epithelium in
the carcinoma
now during our initial
gathering of information on the gene
targets for the multiplex we were aware
that there were
two variants for ms4012 along with a
short variant
so in order to check that the loss of
expression wasn't simply due to a loss
of the generation of the long variant
which was the variant that was being
amplified in the multiplex we conducted
some singleplex we designed singleplex
primers
to each specific teach of the long and
short variants and then conducted a
real-time pcr
and you can see from the charts here
we have normal adenoma and carcinoma
levels of expression of ms4012 long and
short variants and you can see that the
gene expression patterns and profiles
are very similar and for the long and
short variant in each of these tissue
samples
another gene target that was highlighted
has been if a specific interest is lgr5
this of course is
reported to be a colon stem cell marker
and
the cone stem cells are single cells
that reside at the base of the colon
crypts
and
you can see again that the institute
confirms the aberrant expression that we
identified from the multiplex and that
we have
an increase in epithelial expression
showing the bright field image here
by the white staining over the
epithelium
and this is in contrast to the
expression in the single cells
identified at the base of the crypt
and this uh highlighted for us the
sensitivity of the multiplex rc in
detecting this particular transcript
from a very complex tissue sample
and finally i'd just like to point out
cdx2
we followed up and validated this
particular transcript
uh because it was known that ms-4812
actually has a cdx2
responsive promoter in its five-prime
region
and we were
we were aware of course that we had an
increase in cx2 gene expression and
epithelium and the adenoma at the same
time that we had a loss or an s4012
expression
so cdx2
expression in adenoma and upregulation
in adenoma compared to normal was
confirmed by the in-situ hybridization
you can see that there is
an increase in cdx2 expression in the
epithelium of the covalent cryptia as
opposed to the normal tissue
um so and we also then uh followed this
up at the protein level and we're also
able to confirm an upper regulation of
the cdx2 protein in the epithelium
so the reasons why
in its 4012 expression are lost
will require further
investigation
so in summary
the genome system gxp assets
have been validated
against other gene expression technology
platforms
and have proved to perform well
this has permitted us to
custom design a number of rc's and use
them in
general regulatory studies
this has included
looking at hormonal regulation of the
inflammatory targets you know in using
our infamous
and also uh designing uh an assay to
look at tissue uh classification using
predictive gene
signature acids
and more recently we've been actually
applying the multiplex gene expression
assays to uh conduct a blood
human blood gene expression profiling to
look at responses to nutritional
interventions
and i should also say that we've also
been using the multiplex assays
to
assess drug responses using colon tissue
explain cultures
so the custom design options for
relative quantitation of multiple gene
targets
simultaneously within a single reaction
using small
tissue biopsy samples and the improved
data processing time
have presented us with a
feasible strategy
to
measure and identify predictive gene
signature assays
and they demonstrate
potential for clinical utility as a
diagnostic tool to look at disease
initiation and progression and also to
look at therapeutic responses and this
is particularly important as we move to
towards more stratified approaches in
medicine
and finally i'd just like to thank a
number of people who've
been involved in the
development of
multiplex genetic expression assays
these include andrew farkasen who's my
research assistant and he has conducted
most of our gexp assess
our genomics unit to
maintain and organize all the equipment
that we need to run the asses
the statisticians at biomathematics in
statistics scotland
dr claus meyer and dr graham horgan
collaborators at
dundee university professor robert
steele and professor frank kerry
and also the k-side in aberdeen tissue
plants for supplying us with tissue
samples
and i'd also like to thank our funders
of course the scottish government and
nhs grampian
thank you dr drew for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session i'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the q a box which can be
found by clicking on the green q a
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question is a two-parter
first part is what do you think about
the relation between gut microbes and
colon carcinogenesis
and the other part is i also read a
scientific paper that talks about using
a microbial signature as a biomarker for
diagnosis of colon cancer did you happen
to read it and what do you think about
it if you need me to read that second
part again we have to answer the first
one just let me know
hello i haven't read this paper um
specifically um
and certainly um
we do uh have uh
groups working at the institute here who
are looking at the gut microbiota and
links to colon cancer
and certainly it should be possible
to obtain
bacterial samples
from cancer patients and i would think
it would also be possible then to design
um multiplex assays to look at
changes in gut microbiota at the moment
some of the studies we're doing here
we're looking at
the entire gut they tend to be
we're still dealing with big data so
we're still characterizing the gut
microbiome but as we uh
focus and target on specific bacteria or
specific
but
bacterial gene changes associated with
colon cancer
it would then be possible from these
large data sets
to sub select and
as
as
a
perhaps described
select a smaller gene set that could be
used as a kind of signature assay
so i certainly see that that's a
strategy that could be developed
okay there appear to be no further
questions from the audience
answer we will soon conclude the
presentation just want to let you know
we have a quick poll to answer for this
presentation it'll pop up on your screen
in a moment
uh the poll question is having observed
the application of multiplex gene
expression with xp pcr are you planning
to apply this technology in your
laboratory workflow over the next
and then you indicate the
time period
give you a couple of moments to answer
that question
and uh while you're answering that
question i would like to thank our
sponsor av psyx for making today's
educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through november 13
2015. you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to afford that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
see you next time bye
you